[Music]
what up guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whatever we want but today we have a
very special segment for you guys it's
called
ask an expert so i have my own personal
real estate agent here
kevin kwan uh not related but it is
pretty cool that we have the same last
name and he's a real estate agent so
um we're gonna ask him some questions
and hopefully we can share some
knowledge do you guys
have the same last name like spell it
the same way too
yes sir yeah that kwan because there's
also the q-u-a-ns right
yeah and are they the same technically
it depends on how you write the
character in chinese
do your parents know each other i don't
know well you met my dad right or you
talked him on the phone i thought
on the phone yeah
yeah so this is a segment that we
started doing because
a lot of you guys have been asking for
us to have a legit
expert or someone who's uh got
credentials and a professional in the
field so we're gonna start doing
this and i hope you guys like this i
mean we're professional too but he's
just a little
more professional well he has a degree
which is pretty interesting yeah
yeah i feel honored then yeah all right
so first question
how to buy your first home that's a very
good question
um i think the first place you should
always start is probably
talk to a realtor right yeah and when
you do talk to a realtor i think one of
the biggest things that you should
always do
is talk to somebody that does this full
time
oh not a part-time not a part-time agent
not somebody that does it on the side
i think that's one of the biggest pet
peeves for me is
you know the entry level to get your
real estate license
is so easy get your license in now you
can sell real estate right and it's not
too difficult to get a real estate
license but
i always tell people buying real estate
is probably what
the second biggest thing that you do in
your life what's the first
the first is probably retirement right
we work for retirement because we don't
want to work forever dang we're getting
married on your list dude's like number
seven
pretty close cause chicks are expensive
how about buying a car that's pretty big
that might be the third one
oh wait yeah we don't buy expensive cars
so retirement
retirement and then home and then maybe
car yeah or marriage for some people
right or it goes from big to small yeah
yeah so what's wrong with the people
that uh
those part-timers the part-timers uh
well
they don't know the transaction too well
they don't know the process
too well right i always i always kind of
relay it back to
the whole retirement part i mean you
wouldn't want a part-time financial
advisor handling your
retirement right i'm a barber but i
could also handle your finances exactly
right but you have that all the time in
the real estate industry you got a
barber that says oh i do real estate on
the side i can help you with that
right there's there's a lot of things
that you know happen within a real
estate transaction
and with it being such a big purchase
you want to make sure that you have
the right professional helping you how
do i know what are the red flags that i
should look for
in finding a real estate agent where
it's like this guy i don't know about
this guy like a silk tie do they all
work
no i mean everybody's got different
things that they want and want to obtain
right but
i mean usually track record history like
what what exactly that they do right if
they do have another job then
definitely they're not doing this full
time so they might be new
they could be new which is okay right
because you know even
everybody has to start from somewhere
right it doesn't matter what you do you
got to start from somewhere so it's okay
to be new but
you got to be dedicated at the craft of
your business that you want to do
right what about the opposite like let's
say somebody's been doing real estate
for like 20 years they have their
license still
and then they decided you know what i
want to do something else and then maybe
part-time
that could be possible uh but you i mean
if you want somebody to represent you
you want
probably the best person capable for
that job for you
so what's the difference between like a
full-time and part-time as in like
um like are they not paying attention
a hundred percent or how do you what's
yeah what kind of
service is different so like i can tell
just by having a conversation with
another agent on the other side
whether they're probably either new
whether they do this full-time or
part-time
right and the reason why i say you want
to make sure that the person is
full-time because when i start talking
to the people that i know are either new
or part-time
there are things i know i can probably
maybe take advantage in the in the
transaction and
and it's fair because i represent one
side they represent the other side right
so
you might be getting the short end of
the stick in the negotiations right oh
cause they're not
fighting for you because they don't they
don't know that they're getting screwed
over
exactly do you ever go to a friend's
house and you're in their house
and then they tell you how much it was
and you're like oh my god yeah i could
have done so much [ __ ] better
no i try not to do that i just kind of
rethink it though
a little bit maybe i think one of the
first times that i met with him that uh
where he gave me confidence where i want
him to represent me and getting our
first home
was uh we had just like a normal
conversation of
what i wanted my life to be so he was
like
okay so what do i envision in life and i
wanted to be like with my family
and maybe it could be a rental in a few
years so he really got like the gist
of why i'm buying the house first before
going into like the logistics the
strategy
if it's gonna increase in price or
whatever so like that's what i really
liked about him where
like when i talked to some of my mom's
friends it's immediately about
like getting the best deal or how can we
like
this guy out of 10 g's or like how can i
hit him a little bit low and like it's
just all kinds of other like strategy
versus even figuring out if this is even
like the right home for you and then
afterwards when uh when he did find out
that eventually it could be a rental he
was like well like the
number one most rented format for a home
in california
at least is three bedroom two bath so
that immediately like weeded out
anything that was four bedrooms anything
that was two bedrooms
so it was just felt like uh i think that
kind of experience it helped me go okay
this guy really knows the landscape
and and he wants to find the right home
for me
and also i think you know because in the
beginning i don't trust you at all yeah
so in the beginning
when we go look at houses i've also been
to places with my mom
where you can tell that the real estate
agent can't wait to make a sale what
about this one like this one
what's wrong with this one oh that one
that's easy do we just paint that over
but we'll go in a house and literally
within 30 seconds
like this one's not for you and i'm like
are you trying to say no to money
yeah how do you know the difference
between a agent
that only cares about just making a sale
regardless of what circumstance
financial situation you're in
versus someone who's just trying to find
a good fit for the person because like
if i was new
um i just see a dude in the suit and i'm
like i'm trusting you yeah hell yeah
yeah you know more than i do nice watch
dude
you're successful you have a convertible
well i think that's the
the biggest thing is most people what i
found right
is they will just take that first agent
that they get referred to
right oh i got a family friend that does
this or something person that does this
and they
they just rely heavily on that person
right whether it's the right fit or not
so usually even for me
you know i mean everybody's got
different personalities everybody's got
different styles you know i'd love to
help you
i don't have to help you right um do you
cater to
people that way like you you obviously
knew how to how to talk to bart you're
like hey
how do you want to live but do you do
that to everybody or yeah definitely
because and i even tell
tell the people like you should probably
go interview a couple agents just
because someone referred you over to me
doesn't mean i'm necessarily the right
fit
at the same time too right that's good
that's a good negotiating time
i don't [ __ ] need you go go go talk
to people
go talk to people go see how it goes
cutie go ahead sweetie we'll see you
he's the guy that's like just go date
around you know i'm the guy for you but
hey i just want you to know what's out
there
you can't sense that thirst though and
you're like i don't know if i want this
guy
so when you're looking for an agent out
there don't look for a third like
if you feel the thirst you're like uh
get the [ __ ] out of here
something's wrong yeah because it is a
real big relationship that you have
you know between the agent and the
client are there people in the business
that you all as real estate agents know
are like oh god you got that guy holy
[ __ ]
yeah definitely yeah can't say the names
but what do they do like what's the
like why is everyone go oh god that guy
well
i think one of the biggest issues in our
industry i would probably say
i i think you should always have fair
representation right so whenever i talk
to attorneys that want to buy or sell
real estate they're like hey kevin
i only want to represent i only want you
to represent me right and i think that
should be
fair in this business because really if
you're trying to represent both the
buyer and the seller
can you really be 100 fair i think it's
like double dipping yeah i think some
people can do
it but there are some people that are
going to take greed over
you know being fair right um so i think
if we were able to get rid of that rule
it would clean up i would i would i
always say at least 90
of the crap that us agents have to go
through because there are agents where i
just see they look like
gods to the consumer but on the back end
like
real estate agents were just like oh man
another one so for people who haven't
bought
a house or went through the process so
there's an agent that helps
and represents the person who's buying
it but there's also an agent
that represents the person selling the
house that is correct
there could be two agents like two
lawyers in the courtroom correct but it
could be just
one because that person that represents
the seller could also represent a buyer
what are the i guess like not motives
but like what are the goals of each
i mean i mean i feel like the most
simply put probably the buyer wants the
cheapest price
the seller wants the most highest price
but then but besides that like what are
some what are like some of the things
that
they really try to achieve uh i mean
there's also terms within the deal right
like how many days you have to do
specific actions uh in a transaction
but um it might be where a seller has to
stay in a place for a little bit longer
after close the basket
today's video is brought to you by care
of
care of is a wellness brand that makes
it easy to maintain your health goals
with a customized vitamin plan that
helps you feel your best today
and supports you long term and all of
carol's products are formulated with
good for you
clean ingredients that are backed by
science and care of is
super transparent about the research and
sourcing behind
each one of their products so in uh
their five-minute online quiz they ask
you questions about your diet
lifestyle health concerns and help
address your specific wellness goals
and i personally took this and i kind of
appreciate it because
i've already been taking supplements and
vitamins for
some years now and for me to have to go
in and the research like for myself
reading blogs reading
as much as i can to inform myself like
what i should be taking
what the dose is like how much like all
of this
became overwhelming and it took me some
time to custom tailor
like my own thing so to be able to do
this in five minutes
based off of what my needs are i really
appreciated that process
and i'm pretty excited to receive my
first package
so what's really cool right now is that
you can get fifty percent
off your first care of order you just
have to go to take care of
dot com and enter the code off the
record 50.
that's 50 off your first care of order
just go to takecareup.com and enter the
code off the record 50 and you too
and get your own custom recommendation
for vitamins so somebody's watching this
right now they're going how do i
like get my first place like what do you
recommend just as far as like a down
payment like how much
should they save up that's a good
question that was going to be the next
thing that i was going to segue into is
you know after you do talk to an agent
or you can even one or the other can
come first it really
doesn't matter you can but the best
thing is always to talk to a loan
officer
to figure out okay how much can i i
actually afford can he be a barber
he might be a barber but i probably
wouldn't recognize
people so the buyer has an agent but
they also have a loan officer
correct because that's the person that's
going to give you the money to make the
purchase right unless you got
a bag full of cash and you can just say
hey i want to buy this and you don't
need to get a loan right but
majority of the people probably like 85
percent of the people out there
are purchasing with a loan right so
the bank's going to require you to bring
some money to the table and then the
bank's going to give you the rest of the
money but they got to qualify you to
make sure
that you can pay them back and is a loan
officer someone who works at a bank
or do they have their own little thing
or yeah so there's like
different types there's ones that you
can go to like the normal retail branch
like the wells fargos the bank of
america's the chases
then there's mortgage brokers that could
do like they can basically shop around
for best rates
that's what i went to what's better um i
so i always go back the same thing with
like interviewing agents i think you
should interview um
loan officers because everybody has
different personalities and different
styles right
whether somebody might give you the best
rate but he gives you the worst service
or you just don't like the guy
is it worth it at the end of the day i
always say the rates there aren't they
aren't going to change a whole lot so
like you can't you're not going to go to
one guy and he's going to say here's
four percent and the other guy's like
2.5
right they're going to be just off by
like maybe an eighth of a percentage
so what you're really like paying for is
the service the service right because
that's the person that's going to be
engaging with you the entire transaction
i mean you've been through it it's not
it's not an easy process i always say
we have our regular lives and you throw
this on top things just go crazy
yeah right so you want to make sure that
you have good communication skills with
the person that's that's helping you
yeah for me i think uh for our monterey
park house
the developer or the builder for that
community was
i think with walls fargo so i did try to
apply with wells fargo because there's
like incentives correct
but then because of like the nature of
our business they only know how to do
with like w-2s yeah so they saw like my
finances and they're like what the hell
hell no
so we went with like a hell no you make
too much
a family friend of a family friend and
then i think through like one of those
uh mortgage brokers they're able to find
less cookie cutter loans and then
they're able to figure out a way for us
to get that house
yeah and if your loan officer's name is
fat tony run away because that's a loan
shark
that is not a loan officer there's a
difference
if his buttons are undone all the way
here and he has a gold chain and
he has a fat cigar watch out do you
think it's important for people to like
safe up i guess what they think because
like the standard thing you always hear
is
you gotta have 20 for the down right
correct do you think it's important for
people to save the 20
before they even find a loan officer or
final real estate agent or they should
just go out and just start
talking to people if they're interested
in getting a house no i think you should
just start talking
if it has sparked in your mind this is
something that you want to do
go talk to them nobody's gonna charge
you anything right
it's it's a free service they'll listen
to it and i always say it's uh
it's a goal for most people that to want
to buy a house right
and things don't just happen overnight
you have to
plan for it right so if you're not ready
now that's okay but if you make those
steps
to plan for it so you can say okay in
three years or four years
i can save x amount of dollars and i can
finally purchase a house then
at least you're working towards that
goal right as opposed to okay let me
just try to save this and then figure
out okay what i can do but
life changes so quickly like even within
a matter of years
right what makes you stand in a house
next to bart quan
and look around and go this isn't for
him what what do you see what are you
seeing
um i mean i gotta look at what they want
in a house right and then because we've
probably seen a lot more communities
knowing what they want does it have that
as well too right so all that has to
kind of
roll through through my head while we're
we're showing the property plus
you know some houses might have weird
floor plans or there's things that
we've seen that other people might get
overlooked real quick
because maybe the kitchen just stands
out it looks just amazing
right um so those are the things that
really go through our head
one time we were going through this
house and because i probably
before we bought this current house we
probably went through like i don't know
40 or 50 homes yeah
one of the houses we went through he was
like this one's well built and i was
like how do you know he goes look at the
doorknob
and like i get and i felt it i'm like oh
[ __ ]
it was like just like a heavy like not
hollow
doorknob and so he was explaining to me
you could just tell from like the choice
of materials and like what kind of
construction company would be
and so it's not something that you're
gonna buy and all of a sudden like your
pipes blow through
the wall look for the doorknobs out
there uh
but like sometimes like you i remember
one house we looked at it was like an
amazing house
but then right behind it was apartment
complex
right and some people will overlook that
because they're just focused on the
house itself
right not my wife dude i overlooked i
fell in love with that house i remember
that one was next to the sanita mall
yeah and i loved it i was like [ __ ] yeah
and then we found out there was a police
officer i lived on the street
so i'm like i feel extra safe yeah and
then the house was dope
uh and then geo was like i grew up right
next to an apartment complex and at
least the one that she grew up there was
like
drug deals loud 20 cars all the time
she's like it's going to be a [ __ ]
mess all day long and i'm like like
those things you can't control
right because it's not even your
property exactly right and they're like
literally right there so like a lot of
people will fall in love with the house
but then forget about everything else
my friend lives next to like a it's not
a dog pound but they keep like 20 dogs
and they're barking non-stop yeah
it's pretty crazy so like let's say um
people they find okay they find their
real estate agent they find like a loan
officer
the next step is if you have the 20 then
you can pretty much get like the
standard loan what are
all the other loan options like some
people they put zero percent down
i got a fha there yeah there's there's a
million different type of
a million loans maybe maybe isn't fha
four percent of three percent
three point five three and a half
percent what is that one so
i'm not the expert in that but just like
a general idea on it so fha is good for
people that make money but they i mean
especially in california
um prices are just ridiculous right so
to save up for the 20
is really difficult um fha does allow
you to come in with only three and a
half percent
down which is a lot better than twenty
percent uh but there are
additional fees that you would have to
pay so if you have a higher income
earner right that can afford the
payments and can afford the fees it's a
great product right because
now you don't have to shout out to 20
because that could take us another 10
years right
prices could triple by that time who
knows yeah um but
fha is a good program there's even these
cal grant
programs that uh one of i didn't
represent the buyer represented the
seller
but the buyer got a grant from this
california
state program and i think they gave them
up to five percent
which they don't have to pay back after
a certain amount of years wow
right so they basically came in with
almost zero percent down
right um there's other programs that
lenders might have so
five percent down 10 down so it really
depends
on what your current situation is the
loan officer will look at that be like
okay based off of the numbers
this is probably going to be the best
loan for you because this is how much
you're going to pay and so forth
yeah so it's like you don't have to be a
millionaire to buy a house in california
you don't because i got beat
on a property from a person who
qualified for a loan it was a
zero percent loan like not be because i
was able to even submit anything but
they were quick
to to uh go through the offer and
everything
but my agent was like man i never seen
this loan before it's zero percent it's
crazy
you could do that so va right veterans
um they could get what we call va loan
those [ __ ] veterans didn't you use
one you asked
but yeah you could be up to a certain
amount yeah but you could do zero
percent down but
that's california's up like 700 000 or
something yeah
which is still pretty good which is
really good isn't that the price of an
average home here
like 700 grand we're like 750 a little
bit above
750 yeah in l.a county but then they
average it out which is kind of cool
so like it's whatever is above that
limit yeah
uh then you pay percentage on that so it
ends up being you pay total maybe like
two or three percent yeah
so for like our house that we got um i
got the va loan
and my total it was like around like 11
which is still good for like that house
correct
wow is it true that if somebody died in
a house you can probably get a discount
you know it used to be the case to be
honest with you if it's a natural cause
i would probably say in today's world
because it's so crazy out there in the
real estate world
you probably won't um when i first
started the video you won't get a
discount no when i first started in the
business
like they were almost like death forget
it
right that probably would stick on the
market forever but because there's
really no
inventory out there that's the biggest
thing that we're uh
yeah well as long as it's a natural
death if it's like probably a violent
murder or something like suicide or
something like that that happens
if someone got thrown off the balcony do
you put that on the flyer
you have to disclose it right that's
closed maybe not on the flyer
how do you disclose that okay so you're
in the house and they're like oh my god
marquan loves it
he's like this is everything i want i
can see i can visualize type in the
backyard and you're like
hey man listen uh that corner right
there
previous owner that's where he that's
where he killed himself on the balcony a
little bit
is it the seller's agent that has to
disclose correct okay yeah because we
had a house that
was like that some guy died recently in
it and then you were like
you want to get it and i'm like well
there is no inventory so yeah
i mean to be honest with you if it's a
natural death most people are going to
overlook it
like 15 years ago it's like a big no-no
um
so it's a it's a big change but what if
he got shot
that's different there's a bullet hole
still what kind of discount are we
talking if you got shot right
it's different murders or different
whatever yeah like 50 50k
off maybe like a suicide maybe it's more
expensive
that's crazy yeah right now um we're
trying to
get some like airbnb property and this
area that we're looking at it's
it's it's in the woods but it's not that
popular yet
but uh man it's crazy how it got because
right
in december um during the holidays
sales were still happening yeah like we
would wow a property would go up in less
than 48 hours it'll be bought
all cash oh yeah so like and out here
too you're talking about
homes that are cheaper than la so like
400 to 600
000 they'll be like the average out
there and people are
uh like let's say the house is up for
sale for like half a million
it's like 575 or like they're
giving an extra like 80 grand cash on
top
yeah man and we're just like dang dude
this sucks because
you know even if we have like 50 down it
doesn't matter because there's cash
buyers out there
and i'm like why are there so many
people with so much money
buying these houses yeah that's crazy
yeah but it's the same out here like on
in la too right
the cash i would probably say hasn't
been as heavily but
depending on specific price points right
um
i think with coven and everything like
that you have a certain
percentage of people that are just
making a lot of money yeah with kobe
right so all the billionaires in la or
the investment teams
i see so they have a bankroll of their
own cash and they're beating out
just regular people that want a house
that's good i see so we're an investment
team but we're not
we're small that's why we gotta start
somewhere yeah yeah
maybe we'll get another place but um so
to summarize
how to buy your first house you have to
first get your agent
interview them and make sure you get a
good loan officer too
so they can help you strategize the best
like
purchasing method yeah and then you go
out on the search
and hopefully you can find something
that's good for you yep and hopefully
somebody died on this you can get a
little discount a little bit of discount
and hopefully your agent's not a barber
[Music]
too
[Music]
so